So, but let me go now to Kora's
tweet. All right, let's go there
so we can read her post.
All right, let's see here.
Cora Jamie, hold on. Let me see.
All right, there you go. Right here.
Let's look at her post. Here you go.
Here it is. Now, let me show you the
Islamic dilemma.
Okay, now watch how she just destroys
Islam with this comment. It's so sad to
see Christians claim the crucifixion is
the most wellestablished event in
history. Yet, you don't find as much as
one firsthand account to verify it. The
Christians keep proving Quran right.
Now, you know what's ironic? Now, let me
show you some of them. Now, learn how to
debate, how not to debate, how to
evangelize, how not to evangelize.
Learn.
You ready? Learn. Let me see what this
brother.
I'm live my brother. Didn't he confirm
what I said? Everything I said? All
right. Learn. Okay. She says we don't
have any firsthand accounts to verify
the crucifixion.
And yet she will follow
a book, the Quran, which she thinks came
through Muhammad that was composed in
the seventh century.
So she will reject earlier sources about
the historicity of the crucifixion
for a source that she thinks comes from
the 7th century 600s
through a man named Muhammad who was not
there in the first century. Never met
any of the eyewitnesses to Christ. Never
interviewed them. And that assumption is
based on sources that come over a 100
years after Muhammad. Now, let me
explain what I mean. If I were to ask
Kora or Lebaniano, how do you know the
Quran as you have it today existed in
the seventh century?
How do you know that Muhammad,
the name appears only four times in the
Quran, refers to the Muhammad you
believe in
whom you believe was born in 570 AD and
ministered for 23 years? How do you know
what the Quran even is when the Quran
doesn't tell you
what the Quran is? How many chapters
make up the Quran? where the Quran was
composed and when.
Do you get it?
You understand what she just did to her
position? Because they're not interested
in truth. They're not interested in
consistency. They're not interested in
honesty. They just want to bash
Christianity. But they have nothing to
offer. They cannot present to you
Muhammad as a model when you know Jesus
and his example or even follow the
example of Paul. Paul's holiness makes
Muhammad look filthy and rotten. Paul in
comparison to Jesus is a maggot who
wasn't good enough to lick Jesus
sandals. But Paul in comparison to
Muhammad makes Muhammad look like a
maggot who wasn't good enough to lick
Paul's sandals.
But you understand this argument. You
see what she did right now? If she tells
you, well, Muhammad doesn't need to be
an eyewitness or meet the eyewitnesses.
Allah inspired him. So hold on. You're
saying your God can only inspire a man
whom you believe came in the seventh
century,
right? Whom you believe is the one who
recited the Quran as you have it in a
language completely unknown,
not spoken by Jesus or his followers. He
could do that for him 600 years later,
but he can't do it for people writing
only 30 to 60 years later.
You see what I'm doing with the this
argument?
So God can't do
for
the first two generations in the
lifetime of Christ what he did for a man
600 years later assuming your narrative
who spoke in a language not spoken of by
Christ or his followers.
Do you understand what I just did? If
you understand how to use this argument.
All right.
Secondly, the second problem with this,
are you listening now? I need you to
listen so I can move.
The assumption is
that only an eyewitness can write an
accurate report of events. If that
assumption is true, then she just
destroy her hadiths and s. Why? The
oldest extent surah biography on
Muhammad is written 100 years after
Muhammad. That's if we go with the
traditional narrative. Now look at how
many holes. I have to believe Iam wrote
Allah around 750 AD. But where do I get
that from? I don't get it from any
contemporary sources,
inscriptions, writings in the 8th
century. I'm dependent on sources that
come over 200 years later telling me
there was a man named Imak who wrote a
biography in the 8th century. See how
bad it is for them.
Are you understanding how to use this
argument? Okay. So, but I'll be generous
and I'll say, "All right, I will accept
what your sources that come over 200
years later. Tell me about what did
right about 100 years after the death of
your prophet. But even if I go with that
wrote 750 AD
if you're telling me you need an
eyewitness account,
a firsthand account
was not an eyewitness to your prophet
and he's not a firsthand account. Does
that mean you now destroy Islam? Now
you're going to go back and become a
skeptic and now embrace the views of J.
Smith and Robert Spencer and question
the whole narrative about Muhammad and
question whether even Muhammad existed
or are you going to assume like any real
historian does that you can have a
person interviewing
eyewitnesses or interviewing
the followers of eyewitnesses or
consulting sources written by
eyewitnesses? is earlier than him to
give you an accurate historical
narrative.
You get it?
If we follow what she says,
then that means any work written long
after the person and his followers have
died cannot be trusted. This level of
skepticism
destroys not just Islam but any and
every historical writing that wasn't
written by a contemporary.
And now you become complete skeptics of
the entire ancient history. So now
you're going to have to question whether
Jesus existed, let alone right
the crucifixion.
Do you understand how bad it is? This
approach to Christianity will end up
causing her to then question not just
crucifixion, whether Jesus existed. You
have scholars like James Price, I'm
sorry, Robert Price, not James Price,
and Richard Carrier who say Jesus did
not exist. They even question whether
Paul existed. And they even question
whether Ignatius existed.
You see the problem now?
Therefore, she now ends up following a
path that means Islam is false because
by the same historical method, you can't
even prove Muhammad existed.
And then even if you can demonstrate
Muhammad existed, you have no proof that
Jesus existed, which means Islam is
false because it says Jesus did. Do you
understand the problem?
Do you guys understand the problem?
Everyone got the problem with this
approach? Which leads me to the
following questions? How could someone
in the seventh century confirm that what
Muhammad said about Jesus is historical?
You see what she just did? What do I
mean? Understand this argument. How does
she know Jesus's mother's name is
Mediam? Well, the Quran says it. Well,
how can we trust the Quran? Oh, because
the Christian sources. But you just
destroyed the Christian sources.
You understand what I just did here?
How do you know
when Jesus lived, where he lived, and
how do you know
anything about anything he preached and
said? And how do you know why he was
opposed?
And how do you know that someone else
died in his place
if you question the sources that are
closest to the time of Christ? Because
you can't pick and choose. Because
that's circular reasoning. That's
begging the question. That's putting the
cart before the horse. In other words, I
only know that this is true because it
agrees with the Quran. But the Quran is
what we're questioning. You can't tell
me, well, you know that part about
Mediam being her name is right because
the Quran says so. No, we want to know.
How do you know he had a mother named
Mary? See what I'm doing here?
In point of fact, even the name Asa,
there is no right
good solid historical evidence that
suggests that was his name.
Jesus's Hebrew name would have been
Yeshua. Arabic Yeshua. Where did you get
Asa? And how do you know that Asa is the
appropriate form of his Hebrew name? In
point of fact, how do you even know what
his name is? How do you know he was
called Jesus?
How do you know uh any of this?
And then when the Quran tells you his
followers were Muslims, who were his
followers? How many?
Where
did they go? What did they preach? What
century did they preach?
You with me there?
Where did they go? Who did they go to?
What century did they preach?
If you tell me first century, how do you
know that? Oh, from the Christian
documents. But you just called those
documents into question. Why? because
you said they're not firsthand accounts.
So if they're not firsthand accounts and
you can't trust them when it comes to
the crucifixion, how do you know you can
trust them when they situate Jesus in
the first century in Galilee?
How do you know you can trust them in
telling you the name of his followers?
You see what you just did to the Quran?
This is how you attack this argument.
You understand what you just did to the
Quran if you're listening?
Once they question the documents because
of the crucifixion, they cannot believe
anything about Jesus anymore because
they'll tell you, well, his name is
Jesus. How do you know that? Quran says
so. But how do you know the Quran is
right? Because even the form of name
given to him doesn't correspond to the
Arabic form. Well, because of Christian
sources. What sources?
What century? Uh his his mother's name
is Medium. How do you know? How do you
know her name was Media?
Not only that, the Quran says he had
followers. How many, who were they? And
where did they minister? In fact, what
century did Jesus preach?
Are you understanding my questions,
guys? Clip all of these
and upload them to your Tik Tok,
Instagram. Go Twitter, share these
questions. They can't answer.
They can't answer any of these. You with
me there? But contrary to our assertion,
even historians who are not Christians,
who don't think that the New Testament
writings are completely reliable and
think that some of the books are
forgeries,
they all will appeal to the letters of
Paul and the Gospels because even
skeptical scholars date the gospels in
the first century. For instance, liberal
critical dating of the gospels. They'll
say Mark is written between 65 70 AD.
Matthew, Luke, and Acts between 70 80
AD. John 90 AD. But these scholars say
that these documents are based on
earlier sources both written and oral.
So that the material they contain go
back to an earlier period.
So that means when they want to
reconstruct the life of Jesus, they look
to the four gospels, acts and the
letters of Paul,
particularly first Thessalonians,
first 2 Corinthians, Galatians, right?
Philippians